[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci Florian d'être là mon chéri
on fait le point sur les people tous les
vendredis merci d'être là les chéris
d'ailleurs et après Patrick Sébastien
après nous hein
regardez comme elle kiffe Daniel Moreau
[Rires]
les frites sont bonnes du coup
pas mal il faudra qu'on en parle
Florian bonsoir salut bonsoir salut
il parait qu'un Renault a retrouvé
l'amour alors il a retrouvé plein de
choses il a retrouvé l'amour il a
retrouvé la forme et il va peut-être
retrouver le chemin de la scène en fait
c'est une exclu par image qui nous ont
révélé ça hier on le savait depuis
quelques semaines parce qu'il l'avait
dit lui-même il était amoureux d'une
femme enfin il croyait plus mais c'était
pas réciproque il s'est accroché pour
elle il est resté à Paris
de l'Isle-sur-la-Sorgue où il menait une
vie de campagnard loin de de ce qu'il
avait connu et pour elle il est resté à
Paris c'est accroché alors on a rien sur
l'identité de cette femme à part son
visage on ne sait pas comment elle
s'appelle on ne sait pas d'où elle vient
qui elle est mais il est fou amoureux
d'elle je suis content
voilà c'est un amour de mec je l'ai
rencontré un jour voilà je l'adore donc
il a trouvé l'amour il a trouvé l'amour
toujours debout
le troubadour
et donc il a trouvé l'amour il veut que
ça sache parce que les photos qu'on voit
elles ont été tournées elles ont été
prises faire du côté de Montparnasse
mais il y a une autre série qui est pas
encore sortie qui qui a été fait du côté
des Abbesses donc quand on sort
ait du côté des arrêts
et trois choses très importantes c'est
que non seulement grâce à elle enfin
grâce à ce qui vit il veut il veut
retrouver la scène il travaille sur une
tournée ça c'est exclu une tournée
générale une tournée générale
[Applaudissements]
il boit plus et il boit plus vraiment il
boit plus comme Benjamin Castaldi
bois pas on le voit il se met minable à
11h du matin
[Applaudissements]
je rappelle que l'abus d'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé vous avez quand
vous arrivez à 11h du matin et vous
voyez Castaldi frère franchement avec
trois flûtes avec trois flûtes de
champagne tu dis oui bonsoir avec le
père avec le mari Béatrice ou bien il y
a un problème
il boit plus faut voir parce que une
époque il avait dit je ne bois plus du
tout puis après il avait dit bon je bois
encore de la bière je bois encore
et la bonne nouvelle c'est donc qui
réfléchit clairement à remonter sur
scène il travaille sur une tournée donc
il travaille sa voix tous les jours avec
des coachs etc ça c'est une bonne et
selon mes infos il est en discussion
avec TF1
merci au revoir
potentiel nouvelle tournée
d'aller mieux ça c'est quand même cool
la première fois que vous avez entendu
c'est ma grand-mère qui me l'avait fêter
Mistral Gagnant oui
5 minutes
[Musique]
Mistral gagnant c'est la chanson
préférée de France exactement elle a
failli Mistral gagnant c'est aussi la
vie de Gilles Verdez
tu aimes bien cette chanson
que tu sois là tu vois tu es la seule
avec qui je peux parler
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
excuse-moi on a des infos de la star qui
a déjà une polémique des élèves seraient
pistonnés ouais c'est nos amis de public
qui nous racontent tout ça on l'avait vu
déjà lors du premier problème c'est la
nouvelle preuve de chant Adeline qui
connaît deux d'entre la première elle
s'appelle Léa alors à la fin la surprise
lors du premier prime on a bien vu
qu'elle était pas prête pour l'acteur
studio parce que elle savait très bien
depuis le départ que ça Léa était dans
l'émission donc ça c'est la première
chose et nos amis de public nous
révèlent parce qu'ils ont exhumé une
petite vidéo que la prof a elle-même
publiée sur Youtube où on voit Anisha tu
as vu Anisha qui derrière
mais que signifie cette mascarade une
défavoritaire
au-delà de son talent qui est absolument
c'est la chanson c'est la chanson avec
ma cousine mais tu as pas de valeur
là
c'est terminé et et ça va ou pas
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cette vidéo qui a retrouvé public elle
fait partie qu'elle faisait partie du
centre d'art lyrics qui est dirigé donc
par Adeline la nouvelle prof de chant de
la Star Academy et donc ça a beaucoup
beaucoup gueuler sur Twitter
ça ça pose deux problèmes le premier
c'est que ça a pas été communiqué et le
deuxième c'est qu'on se dit qu'elle est
peut-être elle et l'autre Léa favorisée
par la prod et ça c'est pas bien du tout
alors là tu vois là franchement là tu
mets un tu mets un coup de pied dans la
fourmi ah bah c'était le but franchement
mais bon voilà je vais lui demander
l'enquête des amis Jean-Louis blot mon
ami président de dans des moles que
j'embrasse mon frérot d'amour et je vais
te dire alors lui il est complètement
intégré donc je pense qu'il n'est pas au
courant de cette affaire et au pire des
cas qu'est-ce qu'on en a branlé
[Rires]
e
[Applaudissements]
et franchement je dirais on s'en fout
Brad Pitt il est au fond du gouffre
alors ouais ça c'est une petite
extension est-ce que tu connais Brad
pitch chérie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
avec un plus bel épiderme on voit que tu
mets du lait végétal lui doit mettre du
lait animal
lui il va mettre du lait de brebis il a
fait ta salade
tu es vraiment quelqu'un de formidable
vraiment elle trouve beau
[Rires]
c'est génial tu es un amour chéri
tu vois voilà quoi tu vois ça fitte non
mais c'est vrai ça fitte voilà
je peux te payer en carte pokémon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore compter je me sens soutenu
[Musique]
c'est parce que tu ne veux prendre le
jeu prendre la place de personne mais tu
prendras la place de personne ne
t'inquiète pas de toute façon il s'en
foutent